here's the bottom line and i've had calf
strains you know it when you do it you
know when you you know it's something
that it's not like you're done and it's
like oh my leg feels a little weird do
you know when you've stepped yeah and
you've been that great you feel that
grab and as peter king points out in
football morning in america three mris
for andrew luck they still don't know
when this is gonna resolve they don't
know when he's gonna practice again and
it's just a real question for a guy who
answered all questions last year in a
phenomenal way
best season of his career and we thought
these injury issues are behind him for
good now we have a new one and chris
you've been saying all along that the
fact that this thing's still there the
fact that it won't go away there's
something else going on that's causing
this to happen and uh you know this
segment is about big question marks and
i think the biggest question mark right
now is hovering over andrew luck yeah
it's certainly one of them i mean i i
think you know the colts are one of
those teams we're all going oh they're
going to be in the playoffs this year
you know they're probably the the leader
in the clubhouse right now to win the
afc south right i mean they they got to
be on the short list of teams that we
probably would all put as far as super
bowl contenders in the afc like
legitimate super bowl contenders uh so
yeah that is a huge blow to their
football team if andrew luck cannot play
as early on in the season dealing with
this cave injury but it's a big question
mark like i said earlier in the show i'm
not like real concerned yet but this is
concerning that it's continuing to
linger three mris the more you see about
it it just uh you know you wonder how
long this is gonna drag on and the fact
that he's not gonna practice at all
again this week um yeah that is a little
bit troubling and we're getting in you
know getting in some dangerous territory
other quarterbacks with injury question
marks as we approach the 2019 regular
season carson wentz who's been injured
each of the last two decembers and nick
foles has had to come in and save the
day for the eagles and delivered a super
bowl championship and then jimmy
garoppolo who has not played much
football in his career he's got paid a
lot of money by the 49ers he's got to
prove not just that he's healthy he's
got to prove that he is a guy who can
win and perform well on a week in and
week out basis or after this season it
could be no more jimmy garoppolo in san
francisco yeah that's right they can get
out of this deal this year it's uh it's
a very weird situation garoppolo you
know he was built up to be this oh gosh
he's so great all this but we really
don't know what he is yet that's what's
amazing that the guy got a 27.5 million
a year contract with just playing 10
football games um so it is it's a huge
year for jimmy garoppolo in a lot of
ways and the san francisco 49ers
organization in general um but yeah the
quarterback questions they're they're
real i mean like you said garoppolo
wentz you know cam newton dealing
shoulder with the shoulder injury how is
that going to play out as we continue to
go along you know they're just when when
stats send this last night as far as our
rundown question marks in the nfl season
i mean my list just continued to go and
go and go i mean quarterbacks there's
questions all over the league eli
manning drew brees we could get into
that right i mean head coaching
questions all the unproven comments
let's focus let's let's
let's focus on the coaches i know let's
focus on the quarterbacks for now though
yeah you mentioned drew brees right hey
look it's just a given now because tom
brady's playing well and he's two years
beyond his 40th birthday that hey
everybody can do it now if they want to
there were indications last year that
drew brees doesn't have it physically
like he used to we've talked about this
many times taysom hill coming in and
throwing the deep balls drew brees the
first play of the divisional round game
against the eagles they had it dialed up
deep ball to tent again he under threw
it
possibly because he couldn't get any
more on it these are things that we need
to watch and at a minimum it's a fair
question mark the question may be
resolved along the lines of drew brees
is still drew brees but at least for now
it's fair to ask the question and it's
fair to watch and wait and see how it
goes for brees yeah that's right it's
fair to ask the question about a guy
who's what making 27 million dollars a
year and as an nfl legend a first ballot
hall of famer it's not like a disrespect
to his career he's the man you know i
mean couldn't think i can have greater
respect for drew brees and everything
he's done in the nfl career but the
facts of the situation are is he had
three games under 180 yards passing last
year he became a little charlie check
down-ish mike he might have won the
title last year i mean he was tied with
eli as far as intended air yards those
are things that are concerning to me
when you're 28th in football with
intended air yards and then you know
you're 31st in football with longest
completion downfield added to the fact
when they really want to throw the ball
down the field they brought in taysom
hill so yeah those questions are
legitimate this year and it's not
disrespect to breeze or his legacy
you mentioned coaches and there are some
unproven commodities freddie kitchens
who a year ago was the running backs
coach in cleveland and no one would have
put him on a watch list for head
coaching hires for 2019. he's got that
huge weight of expectations they had
over 37 000 people to scrimmage on
saturday ton of excitement in cleveland
but with that excitement comes a very
high bar
and it's going to be you know that's the
exact opposite of cliff kingsbury who is
also completely unproven chris but the
expectations for the cardinals are
minimal yeah in cleveland they couldn't
be any higher yeah it couldn't be higher
i mean it's it's you know it's almost to
the point where i feel like cleveland's
they expect playoffs if they don't go to
the playoffs they're going to be
disappointed you know i think the
reality is they're going to be very much
in the playoff conversation the last one
or two weeks of the year but there's
there's too many things we just don't
know about the team uh the coaches
everything about it right now we got to
see them play some football so yeah it's
uh it's a work in progress but we're all
extremely excited because of what we saw
at the end of last year and we know the
team has a ton of talent especially uh
on both sides of the ball
and how about the jets the expectations
for the jets are fairly low but the idea
that adam gase and greg williams may not
ultimately mix well and maybe things get
a little feisty and cantankerous and
maybe that'll be good for the jets who
knows but that's one that's very
interesting to me yes it is and so is
rogers and le floor
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports